[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
müsste
ich begrüße sie sehr herzlich zum presse
preview im robert-koch-institut heute
ist freitag der 24 april heute mit
professor lars schaade vizepräsident des
robert koch instituts professor weber
war kurzfristig der wir nicht verhindert
wie üblich kommt erste statement und
danach die fragen der angemeldeten
journalisten ja schade bitte ja guten
morgen meine damen und herren ich möchte
zunächst heute mit einem überblick über
die fallzahlen beginnen in deutschland
wurden bis heute 0 uhr 150 1383 cupid 19
fälle übermittelt an das
robert-koch-institut das ist eine
differenz zum vortag von 2337 fällen
insgesamt haben wir darunter jetzt mit
dem heutigen tag 5321 todesfälle das ist
eine differenz zum vortag von 227 fällen
die gesamt incidents in deutschland dass
es die zahl der fälle pro 100.000
einwohner beträgt heute 181 fälle auf
100.000 einwohner
oder anders ausgedrückt eben 1,8 fälle
auf tausend einwohner
diese gesamt incidents hatte ich das
letzte mal bereits erwähnt und das
bleibt auch weiter so variiert stark
innerhalb von deutschland mit zum
beispiel bayern 3 105 fällen auf 100.000
einwohnern bisher in der gesamten
epidemie und mecklenburg vorpommern 41
fällen auf 100.000 einwohner in den
letzten tagen wurden in etwa jeden tag
um die 2000 fälle pro tag neu ermittelt
die zahl der gelesenen wird auf 106.000
800 geschätzt
die produktionszahlen der letzter zeit
so viel gesprochen wurde wird wurde mit
dem gestrigen tag auf 0,9 geschätzt mit
dem datenstand von gestern wäre das eben
das bedeutet dass im mittel fast jeder
eine infizierte person an steckt aber
eben von zehn personen werden dann nach
dieser schätzung neun weitere personen
im moment angesteckt die fallzahl und
die zahl der gelesenen werden täglich
aktualisiert und sie können sie
detailliert auf unserem dashboard die
ist das über unsere homepage erreichbar
ist abrufen weitere informationen im
detail finden sie im situationsbericht
auch mit einer lage einschätzung der
ebenfalls über unsere homepage abrufbar
ist ich möchte da noch mal kurz auf die
internationale situation eingehen dazu
bin ich gebeten worden zu sagen und das
stimmt sicher auch dass die
erfassungssysteme in den verschiedenen
staaten natürlich nicht eins zu eins
vergleichbar sind aber im trend eben
doch vergleichbar und allen fällen liegt
eben zugrunde dass es bestätigte fälle
sind und hier letztendlich auch die
todesfälle den anteil der verstorbenen
unternehmen gemeldeten angeben
in den vereinigten staaten hat es zum
heute oder gab es zum heutigen tag 842
1600 fälle mit 46.000 8 und natur des
vereins das ist ein anteil der
verstorbene von 5,6 prozent und in
europa in den betroffenen staaten in
spanien 208 1400 fälle mit rund 21.700
todesfällen das entspricht einem anteil
von verstorbenen an den gemeldeten von
10,4 prozent in italien 187.000 300
fälle mit 25.000 100 todesfällen an der
verstorbenen 13,4 prozent im vereinigten
königreich 133.500 fällen mit 18.000 100
todesfällen
das entspricht einem anteil von 13,6
prozent und in frankreich 101 119 1200
fälle mit 21.300 todesfällen
was einem anteil von 17,9 prozent
entspricht
ich weiß noch einmal darauf hin dass
dieser anteil der verstorbenen nicht der
vitalität der kogit 19 erkrankung
entspricht weil er meldedaten immer eine
gewisse rolle unter erfassung haben
diese unter erfassung ist in deutschland
zurzeit nicht genau bekannt es gibt
erste hinweise aus serologischen studien
dass sie etwa um den faktor 3 liegen
könnte und weitere studien die diesen
unter erfassung weiter eingrenzen sind
in planung werden auch vom
robert-koch-institut dann unter anderem
in der nächsten woche beginnen
mittlerweile sind weltweit mehr als 2,5
millionen fälle bekannt nahezu alle
länder sind betroffen und besonders
aktiv ist auch weiterhin das
ausbruchsgeschehen im moment in
nordamerika und europa die ausführlichen
zahlen was die betroffenheit der welt
und der verschiedenen länder betrifft
finden sie auf der seite der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und des icd
sie des europäischen zentrums für die
prävention und kontrolle von krankheiten
ich möchte dann im weiteren eingehen auf
die sogenannte über sterblichkeit die in
den letzten tagen auch sehr viel
diskutiert worden ist über sterblichkeit
bedeutet wie viele menschen sterben im
moment durch cupid 19 mehr als es ohne
diese epidemie der fall wäre
beziehungsweise pandemie im weltweiten
maßstab es gibt dafür aus vielen
europäischen ländern erste zuverlässige
zahlen
das ist dann eben nicht der anteil der
verstorbenen unter den gemeldeten
sondern ein bevölkerungs bezogene über
sterblichkeit im verhältnis zu einer
basislinie und dort sieht man dass
einige länder in europa eine zur zeit
wesentlich höhere sterblichkeit zu
verzeichnen haben das ist zb in italien
frankreich und spanien der fall
und diese zahlen die ergeben sich aus
einem europäischen projekt dieses
projekt heißt euro momo und die zahlen
und grafiken sind auch abrufbar im
internet unter www.bmu.de trotz der
massiven maßnahmen die auch einige
dieser länder ergriffen haben ist die
über sterblichkeit dort in diesen
ländern bereits jetzt deutlich höher als
das bei schweren grippe grippewellen der
fall ist die linie der sterblichkeit
geht da zurzeit noch weiter steil nach
oben und in manchen ländern ging diese
über sterblichkeit oder war diese über
sterblichkeit bereits mitte und ende
märz zu verzeichnen man sieht diese über
sterblichkeit gepolt wenn man die
verschiedenen länder gemeinsam
betrachtet auch für ganz europa
vor allen dingen bei den über
65-jährigen aber auch bei den 15 bis 65
jährigen wie sieht diese situation der
übrigen örtlichkeit in deutschland aus
in deutschland gibt es bisher keine
flächendeckende zeitnahe
mobilitätsservice sie gibt es zurzeit
nur in zwei bundesländern nämlich hessen
und berlin
diese daten aus diesen bundesländern
werden auch bei eur mit eingespeist in
deutschland sieht man zurzeit keinen
solchen anstieg wie in den anderen
ländern
das liegt einerseits daran dass wir eben
keine flächendeckende erfassung haben
sondern nur in einigen bundesländern
es gibt auch immer einen gewissen
zeitverzug näher da eine rolle spielt
aber dennoch muss man davon ausgehen
dass in deutschland bislang viele
todesfälle verhindert werden konnten und
zwar auch aufgrund der frühzeitig
eingeführten starken 1 dämmungsmaßnahmen
und ich möchte noch einmal betonen bei
der diskussion die zurzeit läuft es
wurden dabei sicherlich nicht nur
todesfälle durch ko wird 19 verhindert
sondern eben auch andere todesfälle die
geschehen werden wenn das
gesundheitssystem überlastet und
kollabiert wäre das wird noch einmal vor
augen dass wir in deutschland alle
gemeinsam bislang sehr viel erreicht
haben und wie gut wir glücklicherweise
zurzeit dastehen
das paradoxe an dieser situation ist
aber durch den erfolg der maßnahmen
dadurch dass wir keine massive
überlastung des gesundheitssystems keine
massive todeszahlen haben werden die
maßnahmen jetzt von manchen in frage
gestellt manche denken das ist doch
vielleicht alles gar nicht so schlimm
gewesen und warum dann überhaupt all
diese maßnahmen um das noch einmal ganz
deutlich zu sagen wir haben in
deutschland bislang rund 5300 todesfälle
innerhalb nur weniger wochen gehabt
das ist schlimm genug es sind 5300
menschen die aus dem leben gerissen
wurden die familien und freunde hatten
um die getrauert wird die jetzt fehlen
und es werden leider auch noch mehr
menschen sterben
und was die massnahmen betrifft
dass wir in deutschland bislang
vergleichsweise gut durch die epidemie
bekommen gekommen sind haben wir wie
gesagt den maßnahmen zu verdanken dass
die fallzahlen auf einem level geblieben
sind mit dem das gesundheitssystem
umgehen kann und das muss auch so
bleiben
wir dürfen jetzt nicht nachlässig werden
gerade im hinblick auf die ersten
lockerungen dürfen wie wir dürfen jetzt
nicht zu einem erdrutsch an weiteren
lockerungen führen die wieder nach sich
ziehen wenn es wieder mehr enge kontakte
zwischen den menschen geben wird so wie
vorher
dann wird es auch mehr ansteckungen
geben und wenn es wieder mehr
ansteckungen gibt dann entwickelt sich
sehr schnell wieder eine dynamik mit
steigenden fallzahlen und im schlimmsten
fall sind wir dann schnell an einem
punkt angelangt an dem die epidemie
nicht mehr beherrschbar ist und die
kliniken überlastet werden
wir haben das in anderen ländern gesehen
und wir haben auch gesehen wie schnell
das passieren kann
deshalb meine eindringliche bitte noch
einmal halten sie sich weiter an die
massnahmen und empfehlungen bleiben sie
so weit es geht zu hause halten sie sich
an die kontakt beschränkung halten sie
weiter abstand voneinander mindestens
1,5 besser zwei meter halten sie sich an
die husten und niesen regeln und wenn
sie im öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
unterwegs sind oder in einem geschäft
sind tragen sie zusätzlich einen mund
nasen bedeckung um andere zu schützen
helfen sie dabei das virus weiter in
schach zu halten
und ich möchte mich noch einmal ganz
ausdrücklich bei allen menschen in
deutschland bedanken dass sie sich
bisher in den vergangenen wochen so gut
an diese massnahmen und empfehlungen
gehalten haben mir ort mir und uns ein
hierarchie ist bewusst wie schwierig
diese zeiten sind für alle das viele
menschen menschen am rande ihrer kräfte
sind dass es auch viele existenzängste
gibt und glauben sie mir bitte
auch ich würde mir nichts mehr wünschen
als ihnen sagen zu können dass es vorbei
ist
aber es ist noch nicht vorbei leider ist
es noch nicht vorbei und es ist unsere
aufgabe als wissenschaftler zu sagen was
ist wie wir die aktuelle situation auf
basis unserer wissenschaftlichen
informationen
einschätzen ich freue mich jetzt auf
ihre fragen vielen dank
vielen dank herr schade
dann beginnen wir mit der welt die frau
will entschuldigung ich habe den
falschen geklickt die frau will vw
gehören sie uns ja wir haben sie also
das ist eine gute frage also diese
dieser wert den wir für deutschland
bestimmen oder schätzen den schätzen wir
ja mit mathematischen methoden der setzt
sich natürlich zusammen aus mehreren
geschehen das sind geschehen die in den
bundesländern unterschiedlich sind oder
auch in den regionen das kann man jetzt
auch sehen es gibt bundesländer in denen
dieser erwert noch knapp über 1 licht es
gibt andere da liegt er schon deutlicher
unter 1 und gleichzeitig auch in
verschiedenen bevölkerungsgruppen vettel
bespielen sich verschiedene geschehen ab
es gibt eben ausbrüche auch recht große
ausbrüche in gemeinschaftsunterkünften
und heim
da ist dann natürlich in diesem in
diesem setting über das nennen der wert
deutlich über 1 zurzeit dann und all das
summiert sich dann natürlich zu einem
mehrwert der für deutschland zu
bestimmen ist im moment sehen wir eben
gerade solche ausbrüche dass das gerade
solche ausbrüche auch eine eine rolle
spielen
daraus jetzt zu schließen dass die
maßnahmen nicht wirksam sind wäre aus
meiner sicht der falsche schluss denn
diese cluster die sind ja untereinander
verbunden sonst würden die ja nicht
entstehen irgendeiner schleppt zum
beispiel eine gemeinschaftsunterkunft in
ein altenheim wie auch immer ein virus
ein und
das kommt von außen dann und je mehr das
virus in der bevölkerung zirkuliert umso
häufiger würden natürlich auch solche
einstellungen in entsprechende
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen in bestimmte
gemeinschaften sein und das zu
verhindern dass das virus eben frei in
der bevölkerung zirkuliert und dann von
dort einbricht in bestimmte wohlrabe
gruppen zb oder risikogruppen
das ist ja das ziel dieser maßnahmen die
zirkulieren des virus in der bevölkerung
zu verhindern und ich denke dass diese
maßnahmen diesbezüglich sehr erfolgreich
waren
da sehen wir auch an anderen
erfassungssystemen wie wir haben wir
haben zb erfassungssysteme die auf
bevölkerungs ebene ein biologisches wir
jetzt machen welche wären
respiratorischen wären gerade
zirkulieren
das haben wir für die krippe
eingerichtet das funktioniert aber
grundsätzlich natürlich auch für das
kona virus und da sehen wir eben nur
sehr selten nachweisen das heißt die wir
ist regulation in der breiten
bevölkerung ist gering und das ist
sicherlich diesen maßnahmen zu verdanken
vielen dank
wir gehen zu reuters herr wackelt wir
haben sie eigentlich derzeit möglich und
wenn ja wo ist die grenze die sünder
müssen wir das nicht mehr können
also da kann man sicherlich jetzt keine
ganz scharfe grenze nennen
ich denke das ist jetzt meine meine
einschätzung zu der zu dieser frage dass
eine zahl von etwa 2.000 fällen pro tag
das wäre noch sehr viel wenn man sich
das jetzt umrechnet aufgibt etwa 400
gesundheitsämter dann hätte jedes
gesundheitsamt sowie etwa zweieinhalb
fälle pro tag
richter verrechneten sind mit deutlich
mehr fünf fälle pro tag und das ist
natürlich recht viel das klingt erst mal
wenig aber jeder dieser fälle hat ja
auch wieder kontakte und diese kontakte
das wissen wir allerdings kontakten
ersten grades die haben wir haben ein
risiko selbst zu erkranken dass ungefähr
bei zehn prozent liegt ein bisschen
drunter so etwa 8 prozent und die müssen
eben alle auch benachrichtigt werden
die müssen alle in quarantäne geschickt
werden und diese kontakte können eben
pro einzelfall sehr viele sein kann 20
52 teilweisen das eben auch 100 und das
multipliziert sich dann eben sehr
schnell so dass hier sehr schnell auch
die grenzen des gesundheitsamtes
erreicht sind das ist ja genau der grund
warum es jetzt so wichtig ist bei den
gegenwärtigen fallzahlen eben auch noch
weiter andere maßnahmen zu ergreifen das
sind die maßnahmen des persönlichen
verhaltens die ich ja erwähnt hatte
das sind aber auch noch maßnahmen auf
bevölkerungs ebene das eben bestimmte
einschränkungen bestehen bestimmte
veranstaltungen zu besuchen nicht in
restaurants zu gehen wie es derzeit der
fall ist und so weiter und so fort die
einschränkung in den geschäften ohne
diese maßnahmen wäre das im moment
sicherlich sehr schwierig all diese
neuen diese neuen infekt ketten die sich
dann bilden würden ausgehend von den
erkrankten dann auch zu beherrschen
eine sichere zahl kann ich ihnen da
nicht nennen aber ich würde denken das
ist schon erforderlich ist dass diese
fallzahlen auf wenige hundert pro tag
sinken bevor dann man über weitere oder
auch eine weitgehende lockerung der
maßnahmen nachdenken kann
die kann man also frühestens nach zwei
wochen sehen also wir haben ja ein maile
verzug von zwei wochen
es ist vielleicht nicht ganz fair das
wort melde verzug es ist eine
zusammengesetzter verzug aus diagnose
verzug das ist im grunde der größte teil
wenn eine person krank geworden
da muss sie erstmal sich anschließend
zum arzt zu gehen der arzt macht dann
die diagnose wenn die diagnose dann vor
liegt davon gehen etwa fünf tage nach
den ersten symptomen und dann erfolgt
noch die meldung ans gesundheitsamt und
dann weiter an uns dieser verzug
alles in allem inklusive der
inkubationszeit die ist ja noch davor
bevor die person krank wird es dauert in
etwa zwei wochen
das schwankt so ein bisschen je nachdem
wie belastet auch die gesundheitsämter
sind aber mit zwei wochen hat man da so
eine app etwa eine richtschnur nach zwei
wochen sehen wir frühestens positive
oder auch negative auswirkungen von
maßnahmen in den meldezahlen vielen dank
und bei der gelegenheit noch die
erinnerungen dann das hand symbol wieder
zu klicken damit sie aus der liste
herausfallen
wir gehen zu hören caracciola der
tagesschau hallo tagesschau hmm schade
problems gleich nochmal und gehen zur
zum zdf zur sportredaktion herr jacobs
ist bei dem gerät jetzt ein konzept
vorgelegt wie in der stimme der
bundesliga im geiste starten kann dazu
gehört auch ein umfangreiches viel jenen
konzept die ministerpräsidentin der
nächste woche darüber beraten
ministerpräsident müller hat schon
gesagt die ezb hat auch die einschätzung
des robert koch instituts wie bewerten
sie denn dieses beginne konzept also
gronert es einen tag vor dem spiel vor
dem stadion zb online teilgruppen auch
der erklärte wille der gesellschaft
keine test kapazitäten wegzunehmen und
auch die überlegung dass wenn ein
spieler positiv besetzt ist dass man
dann beschränken
da kommen ist also nur der spieler
kontaktperson aber nicht die ganze
mannschaft
ich hatte mich schon am dienstag dazu
geäußert und inzwischen ist ja denke ich
auch so richtig die veröffentlichung in
der presse deutlich geworden dass es
sich hier um ein problem letztendlich
des arbeitsschutzes handelt denn das
sind ja fußballprofis dass es deren job
und insofern gibt es da ein konzept das
von der arbeitsschutz seite erstellt
worden ist und was dort drinsteht was
die überlegungen angeht bezüglich einer
einer quarantäne und das mit einer
quarantäne zu lösen
das scheint mir durchaus vernünftige
überlegungen zu sein aber es ist einfach
nicht die zuständigkeit des
robert-koch-instituts sich dazu jetzt
weiter zu äußern
wir probieren es noch mal mit der
tagesschau apache vielzahl und falls ja
wie sehen die genau aus empirisch
gesicherte daten zu erzeugen und zu
lassen es gibt ja immer noch die
forderung großen teilweise ja es gibt
also diese stichproben werden jetzt
beginnen die großen stichproben das
werden wir machen das werden auch die
beiden machen werden eine eigene
untersuchung machen es gibt auch das
helmholtz zentrum noch weitere
untersuchungen machen also da werden wir
in zukunft mehr klarheit gewinnen aber
eben auch nicht zu allen fragen also was
die unter erfassung angeht da werden wir
ein klareres bild bekommen zum beispiel
was jetzt andere fragen angeht den
genauen erkrankungs zeitpunkt zb
da werden wir auch weiterhin auf auf
schätzungen angewiesen sein
nur kurz zum hintergrund bei den
meldungen die wir bekommen da ist auch
eine frage wann war der
erkrankungsbeginn der erkrankungsbeginn
ist bei etwa 60 prozent der meldungen
auch angegeben bei den anderen nicht und
das wäre zum beispiel so eine sache dass
wir schätzen müssen dann aus dem mail
datum und aus der üblichen verzögerung
zwischen meldungen
krankheitsbeginn wie es denn wohl der
krankheitsbeginn der anderen fälle
gewesen das ist zum beispiel eine sache
da wird es immer eine gewisse
dunkelziffer geben je vollständiger die
meldungen sind umso präziser wird dann
die schätzung dass das 100 prozent sind
das weiß man einfach auf solchen
erfassungssystemen das wird vermutlich
nicht der fall sein in absehbarer zeit
und das ist dann auch der grund warum
die werte die wir darauf aufbauen eben
auch geschätzt sind zum beispiel der
wert den wir nämlich beziehen auf den
erkrankungsbeginn vielen dank wir gehen
zu n-tv heran um 1 lässt indem er ist
eigentlich in diesem geld kommen können
oder das installieren von der unzeiten
bestehen im hotel ziehen erst und
desinfektionsmittel spritzen sollte auf
die deutschland retten lassen müssen und
der sommer ist ja also zur frage der
saisonalität die ist ja schon häufig
diskutiert worden
da gibt es eigentlich immer noch keine
besseren zahlen zu wir müssen einfach
abwarten wie sich das entwickelt bei uns
ob der sommer da ein unterschied macht
da gibt es eben die physikalischen
faktoren das eben möglicherweise das
virus in der warmen luft und mit den
sonnenstrahlen dann weniger oder
schneller inaktiviert wird das ist eine
möglichkeit das weiß zurzeit niemand so
genau
auch menschliches verhalten ist im
sommer anders leute sind mehr draußen
dadurch ergibt sich an vielen stellen
ohnehin mehr abstand
das alles sind faktoren das ist besser
als wenn man einem unbelüfteten raum ist
und dass damit mal zu vergleichen die
grundsätzlich zur saisonalität beitragen
können ob das bei diesem virus so ist
weiß man nicht aber es gibt eben auch
infektionsfälle auf der südhalbkugel
oder gab die im frühjahr wo ja
eigentlich dann auch schon wärmere
temperaturen geherrscht haben ganz groß
wird dieser effekt sicherlich nicht sein
wenn er wenn er überhaupt da ist also
das ist weiterhin der hoffnung aber ich
denke darauf kann man sich nicht
verlassen
bezüglich der reduktion des erwerbs das
ist da stimme ich herrn drosten mit dem
völlig überein
je weiter dieser wert unter geht umso
besser ist das für uns vor allen dingen
dann wenn wir eben immer weiter auch mit
maßnahmen zurückfahren wollen man kann
sich ja vorstellen dass wir wenn es nur
noch wenige fälle sind ein zwei fälle
die woche in deutschland um jetzt mal
diese zahl zu nennen dass man damit
ausreicht wenn man diese fälle schnell
identifiziert und eine kontaktsuche
macht es ist ja auch ganz am anfang in
bayern gelungen ein die diesen cluster
auf diese art und weise zu 1
einzugrenzen
solange diese werte noch nicht so
niedrig sind wird es sicherlich
notwendig seien noch zusätzliche
gesellschafts bezogene maßnahmen zu
ergreifen damit eben das virus nicht
wieder beginnt sich in der bevölkerung
zu vermehren und wieder explosionsartig
sich zu vermehren dieser
sicherheitsabstand von 1 nach unten der
ist sicherlich sehr wünschenswert und
wie ich wünsche mir auch dass wir es uns
gelingt den in zukunft noch zu erreichen
und man muss da eben letztendlich jetzt
eine balance finden zwischen maßnahmen
sowie sie gesellschaftlich angemessen
und akzeptiert sind und dem einfluss auf
den eher wertes ist es hat die kanzlerin
ja auch gestern noch mal betont das ist
ein sehr schwieriger balance akt auf
sehr dünnem eis nicht kann ich mich nur
anschließen
man sollte das sehr vorsichtig und den
sehr vorsichtigen schritten machen und
aufpassen dass der wert am besten auch
unter dieser lockerung der maßnahmen
weiter sinkt und das haben wir eben alle
durch unser eigenes verhalten zusätzlich
auch noch mit der hand
sie schreiben helfen würde von heute die
spritpreise gestern vor vernünftig bauen
das mit dem schulhof in welchem ausmaß
die am ausgehen dass die zahlen der
stadt müsste man doch einen ersten fall
sein müssen die zahl auch noch weiter
als sehr stark und erfahren dass ganz
loslassen
also wir hatten ja das denke ich nicht
geschrieben wir hatten gesagt dass es
eine gewisse möglichkeit ist dass bei
schuleröffnung auch es wieder zu
infektionen kommen kann das ist glaube
ich erst mal auch jedem klar und nicht
so ungewöhnlich und wir haben dann auch
vorgeschlagen welche grundsätzlichen
wägemann einschlagen könnte um dieses
risiko zu minimieren
da gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
das risiko wird dadurch nicht auf null
gehen
und ich denke man muss sich dann wenn
ein ausbruch dann in einer schule
passiert eben auch sehr schnell
reagieren um diesen ausbruch dann
entsprechend einzudämmen und die nicht
von dort aus weiter in die gesellschaft
zu tragen und man muss denke ich auch
die bereitschaft haben jedenfalls aus
unserer sicht aus der epidemiologischen
sicht wenn man eben sieht dass das
regelhaft und häufig der fall ist dass
es zu diesen infektionen in schulen
kommt zurück infektions clustern dann
muss man sich auch noch mal überlegen
diese maßnahmen wieder anzuziehen
ich gehe jetzt ich kann jetzt nicht
davon ausgehen so möchte ich nicht
verstanden werden dass es auf jeden fall
durch die schuleröffnung zu einer
flächendeckenden verbreitung jetzt
wieder des virus kommt das risiko ist da
man kann es minimieren
durch maßnahmen im laufenden betrieb und
wenn man eben sieht dass diese maßnahmen
nicht ausreichen und ist dann zu einer
zu einem befeuerung der epidemie wieder
kommt denke ich sollte man auch jetzt
schon sich überlegen was man dann tut um
die maßnahmen wieder anzuziehen
vielen dank beginn zur taz herr
kreutzfeldt
dahinter schade ich also fragen zu dem
test kapazität und den durchgeführten
tests da wird man wieder betonen wie
wichtig ist ist eine muss klicks bezahlt
und text zu haben das ausbildungs
geschehen zu verstehen und eindämmen zu
können nun bis in den letzten wochen
nach ihren angaben die zahlen die
kapazität weiter beschrieben auf 820.000
die zahl der durchgeführten test ist
aber stark gesunken auf 320.000 40
prozent auslastung
und da würde ich es nochmal hören waren
warum wird so wenig getestet liegt es
daran dass die kriterien zu strecken
sind und angepasst werden müssten oder
liegt am mangel an verbrauchsmaterialien
oder was ist da sonst los ja also in
mangel an verbrauchsmaterialien kann
hier und da auch mal eine rolle spielen
lokal das ist aber sicherlich kann kein
flächen des kein flächendeckendes
problem wir haben letztendlich die
testkriterien ja in der vergangenheit
auch schon immer empfindlicher gemacht
ja wir haben unterscheiden jetzt erst
mal grundsätzlich in den testkriterien
von zwischen einem verdachtsfall im
verdachtsfall es eben jemand der
symptome hat und mit einer mit einem
bestätigt kranken in kontakt war oder
eben jemand der eine lungenentzündung
entwickelt in einem cluster von
lungenentzündungen also klassischerweise
eben zb in einem in einem in einer
pflegeeinrichtung das sind
verdachtsfälle sie sollten unbedingt
getestet werden und auch
hygienemaßnahmen sind einzuhalten und
darüber hinaus haben wir eben auch den
test empfohlen zur differentialdiagnose
wie das medizinisch heißt das heißt zur
abklärung wenn bestimmte
krankheitssymptome vorliegen was die
ursache dieser krankheit symptome ist
auch wenn man jetzt nicht sofort denkt
dass es wird wohl ein coup 19 fall sein
und unter diesen kriterien haben wir
eben schon seit über einem monat auch
gesagt jede atemwegsinfektion also auch
jede leichten infektion ohne einen
spezifischen risikofaktoren oder ohne
eine oder einen kann ohne ein kontakt zu
einer erkrankten bestätigten erkrankten
person sollte getestet werden sofern
ausreichend test kapazitäten zur
verfügung stehen und wir haben jetzt in
dieser woche
diese diesen zusatz sofern ausreichend
test kapazitäten zur verfügung stehen
weil das eben so ist nach den zahlen
dass dieser test kapazitäten jetzt da
sind gestrichen so dass wir dringend
empfehlen zur zeit dass jeder der eine
atemwegsinfektion hat das geht mit
halsschmerzen los und endet natürlich
bei husten oder auch atemnot und fieber
dass jeder egal welcher schweren
atemwegsinfektion hat auch getestet
werden sollte zurzeit zur sensitiven
findung im moment ist das von den
kapazitäten her möglich und sicherlich
auch eine wichtige maßnahme um fälle
schnell zu erkennen und dann zu
isolieren und deren kontakte in
quarantäne zu schicken
also es gibt von uns empfehlungen dass
man kontaktpersonen unter bestimmten
umständen regelmäßig am besten täglich
oder zwei täglich testen kann wenn zum
beispiel personalmangel herrscht im
krankenhaus ja dass es eben nicht dazu
kommt dass patienten nicht mehr versorgt
werden können
gleichzeitig sollten die natürlich auch
einen einen mund nasen schutz tragen er
auf sich auf sich achten dass über jedem
symptom sofort geben entsprechend sich
auch aus der arbeit zurückziehen und
sich testen lassen und zusätzlich eben
regelmäßig getestet werden
als generelle methode sozusagen um
personen nicht in quarantäne zu schicken
bevölkerungs weit da halten wir
eigentlich das testen von
asymptomatischen personen nicht für den
richtigen weg
schlicht und ergreifend deshalb weil ein
einzelner test oder auch ein test der
mit einem abstand von einigen tagen
durchgeführt wird und der negativ ist
eben nicht besagt dass diese person
nicht infiziert ist solange dieser test
in der inkubationszeit durchgeführt wird
und die kann eben bis zu 14 tagen
bestehen kann ein zwei stunden oder auch
am abend desselben tages nachdem der
test negativ war
die virus ausscheidungen beginnen und
dann ist diese person infektiös und
selbst wenn man ein engmaschiges test
fenster hat und das zur regel macht von
sagen wir zwei tagen würde das bedeuten
dass diese personen infektiös kontakt zu
anderen haben kann und deshalb ist die
sichere variante und deswegen empfehlen
wir das auch ganz grundsätzlich
kontaktpersonen ersten grades und nur
die also die einen engeren kontakt
hatten sollten 14 tage in quarantäne
verbringen
ausnahmen nur dann wenn die eben einen
mundschutz tragen und wenn es eben eine
zwangslage gibt die es erforderlich
macht dass dieses personal weiter tätig
ist unter diesen strengen auflagen und
dass es eben nicht nur die testung
sondern auch das permanente tragen eines
mundschutzes vielen dank bevor wir zum
südwestrundfunk kommen nochmal die bitte
dass diejenigen die ihre frage gestellt
haben
auch wieder auf das hand symbol klicken
damit sie aus der liste herausfallen
grundsätzlich verstehen sie das richtig
wir hatten im letzten monat
das ist ziemlich genau vor einem monat
gewesen eben noch dieser einschränkung
eingebaut sage ich mal
sofern test kapazitäten zur verfügung
das war da so noch nicht ganz klar und
es gab zumindest regionale engpässe und
wir haben diese passage gestrichen so
dass nach unserer empfehlung das ist ja
das ist ja eine empfehlung wir können ja
jetzt keinen arzt anweisen einen test
durchzuführen oder eben nicht
durchzuführen dass eine fachliche
empfehlung und die lautet eben
atemwegsinfektionen jeder schwere
sollten auf coop mit 19 getestet werden
der grund dafür ist sind im grunde drei
gründe die da eine rolle spielen und
pleite und das noch mal zu sagen und zu
vervollständigen das eine ist
dass wir eben jetzt kehrt test
kapazitäten zur verfügung haben das
zweite ist dass die erkältungssaison
vorbei ist und man einfach auch mehr
treffer erwarten kann früher sagen wir
mal im anfang märz da war es einfach
noch wahrscheinlicher dass man auch eine
normale erkältung hat als ein qubit 19
virus virus war ja zwar in deutschland
aber nicht flächendeckend in der
bevölkerung zu einem gewissen
prozentsatz verbreitet und der dritte
grund ist dass wir natürlich gerade
jetzt wo wir die maßnahmen schrittweise
lockern bzw
die politik die maßnahmen schrittweise
lockert gerade jetzt es besonders
wichtig ist ganz empfindlich sensitive
wie wir das nennen auch in der lage zu
sein
coop mit 19 fälle schon bei kleinen
symptomen zu erkennen es gibt sicherlich
einige fälle die schon das virus auch
ausscheiden bevor die symptomatik da ist
aber die kann man eben nicht da kann man
eben nicht äußern das dass da ein
gewisser verdacht besteht aber sowie
atemwegs und oma bestehen dann sollte
auch ein test durchgeführt werden
identifizieren gelockert
mehr menschen begegnet ist masken das
risiko an
das kann ihnen so mit zahlen belegt
niemand wirklich sagen also das licht an
zwei dingen also zunächst mal
wir reden ja hier entweder über den mund
nasenschutz den medizinischen und
nasenschutz der sollte natürlich in
erster linie s hatte ich letzten mal
auch betont den medizinischen personal
vorbehalten sein gleichwohl sieht man
die natürlich auf der straße und wir
reden von dann diesem sogenannten
alltags masken oder mund nasen bedeckung
und die sind ja aus ganz
unterschiedlicher qualität
diesen mehrlagig diesen teilweise aus
papier die sind aus verschiedenen
stoffen teils mit fütterung und so
weiter und so fort
und deswegen kann man eben nicht
generell sagen wie stark diese wirkung
wir haben uns jetzt entschlossen wie das
tragen von masken in der öffentlichkeit
als zusätzliche maßnahme zu empfehlen
weil wir eben wissen und dafür gibt es
auch neuere daten auch daten mit dem
corona virus dass der mund nasen schutz
dieser medizinische mund nasenschutz
durchaus eine gewisse verminderung der
virus ausscheidung bewirken kann und es
gibt eben auch hinweise die sind nicht
ganz so stark dass das auch noch bei
einer anderen stoff barriere vor mund
und nase der fall ist das ist aber nicht
hundertprozentig sondern das ist eine
eine reduktion um einen gewissen betrag
der zusätzlich zu den abstand maßnahmen
zusätzlich zur hygiene auch bevölkerungs
ebene versprechen wir uns davon eine
eine zusätzliche reduktion der
ansteckungsrate und wichtig ist eben
auch noch zu betonen dass eben man nicht
davon ausgehen kann dass der mund
nasenschutz oder auch diese mund nase
bedeckung aus einfachen stoffen einen
selbst schützen können also um sich
selbst zu schützen ist es eben weiter
wichtig abstand zu halten und die
hygienemaßnahmen einzuhalten sondern
dies ist eine altruistische maßnahme die
in erster linie dazu dient das
versprühen von kleinen tropfen die
entstehen können durch diese barriere so
zu behindern dass eben diese tropfen
nicht so weit fliegen um dann andere
infektionen bei anderen menschen setzen
zu können und auf bevölkerungs ebene
versprechen wir uns da eben einen
gewissen effekt von und dafür spricht
unter anderem auch das tragen dieser
masken in asiatischen staaten gerade bei
der kogit 19 epidemie wo er einige auch
gute erfolge nachzuweisen haben einige
staaten
vielen dank mit gen zum focus herr meier
söder hat gewisses über die nicht
geäußert wenn eines tages der regen
statt bar ist ließ mich den sie dazu und
gibt es erfahrungswerte wie viel prozent
der deutschen sich eigentlich ihn
verlassen müssten games auf zwei erhöht
das virus so auszudrücken sieg wird ja
also da will ich auch ganz gern mit der
zweiten frage anfangen das ist im grunde
die frage nach der herdenimmunität ob
man nun immun ist weil man dass die
infektion durchgemacht hat oder im mund
ist weil man eine impfung bekommen hat
das spielt eigentlich keine rolle
die erhärten immunität die erreicht
werden muss um eine virus verbreitung
einzugrenzen die hängt von diesem r null
wert ab von dem wir gesprochen hatten
und bei dem er über den wir da haben das
sind das eben in etwa 60 bis 70 prozent
also sagen wir mal 70 prozent der
bevölkerung wenn die geimpft sind dann
kann man davon ausgehen dass eine herren
immunität eintritt und das wäre auf
jeden fall das mindestziel was dann
erreicht werden sollte ob man das nun
durch eine impfpflicht erreicht oder
durch eine durch eine empfehlung dass
das ist eine frage die die ich zurzeit
nicht beantworten kann ist auch eine
politische frage ob man das möchte mit
einer entsprechenden pflicht ich würde
zurzeit einfach davon ausgehen dass wenn
ein impfstoff zur verfügung steht der
nach den daten sicher und wirksam ist
dass es dann keine akzeptanzprobleme
gibt und dass diese diese schwelle von
diesen 70 prozent auch durch eine
empfehlung sehr schnell erreicht werden
sollte sollte das nicht der fall sein
was ich nicht glaube wie gesagt kann man
natürlich immer auch noch über eine
impfpflicht nachdenken
aber ich würde im moment denken dass die
akzeptanz da er als sehr hoch zu
erwarten wäre
vielen dank frau satori vom wdr
hören sie können sie nicht dort
wenigstens das personal zweimal die
woche testet unmöglich ja das ist das
ist nicht so dass es nicht gemacht wird
also wir empfehlen dass zum beispiel
sehr dringend dann wenn ein ausbruch
dort stattfindet in diesen heimen das
dann auch als symptomatische personen
regelmäßig getestet werden in diesem
aufbruch szenario und darüber hinaus
gibt es bereits jetzt einrichtungen die
auch genau das machen wie eben personen
testen die neue einige die neu
aufgenommen werden in diesen
einrichtungen oder auch die ihr personal
regelmäßig testen es sicherlich jetzt
auch gerade in der diskussion und der
abstimmung ob man das als generelle
empfehlung flächendeckend so machen will
da muss man sich dann auch überlegen
auch diese 880.000 teste die dann zur
verfügung stehen theoretisch zur
verfügung stehen in der woche die sind
dann irgendwann endlich ich habe da die
zahl im kopf dass es in deutschland etwa
15.000 stationäre pflegeeinrichtungen
gibt altenpflegeeinrichtungen und
anderer pflegeeinrichtungen mit dann
entsprechend ja natürlich relativ viel
personal pro einrichtung die müssten
regelmäßig getestet werden dazu kommt
noch der ambulante bereich also ich
glaube dass man auch damit einer sehr
hohen test kapazität irgendwann an
grenzen stoßen wird und das in gewisser
weise ein grenzen muss dass es der punkt
1 der dazu bedenken ist und der punkt
zwei ist eben personen die mit
risikogruppen jetzt umgehend im bereich
der pflege
die sollten auf jeden fall einen mund
nasen schutz tragen zum fremdschutz dann
sag ich mal wenn man jetzt die
vorstellung hat man wird
zwei oder drei tage oder auch vielleicht
nur zwei mal in der woche weil das
häufig gar nicht möglich ist
getestet und damit sei man sicher die
ist ebenfalls ein negativer test
bedeutet nicht dass man nicht infiziert
ist und kurze zeit später das virus
schon ausscheiden kann
es wäre also immer eine zusätzliche
maßnahme zusätzlich zu mund nasen schutz
und das ist eine ganz wichtige sache das
zu betonen
also die vorstellung dass man durch
häufiges testen letztendlich
ausschließen kann dass eine person in
die nächsten infiziert ist und in den
nächsten stunden oder tagen dann zum
ausscheiden des virus wird die ist
einfach falsch dann kann das mit einem
negativen test nur weniger
wahrscheinlich machen aber man kann es
nicht ausschließen
also braucht man alle anderen maßnahmen
die man hier zum schutz einführen kann
abstand halten hygiene und gerade
natürlich wenn man körpernah arbeiten
machen muss in der pflege eben auch der
mund nasenschutz die müssen unbedingt
erhalten bleiben also zu den fußballern
wie gesagt hatte ich mich glaube ich
abschließend geäußert und auch gesagt
dass das jetzt richtig verortet bei den
bei den für den arbeitsschutz
zuständigen behörden ist die andere
frage
können sie sich noch mal kurz
wiederholen entschuldigung
die irin auslasten kann ausdruck gibt es
gesagt wir machen ja dass polen er
sicherlich eine eine idee oder eine
möglicherweise auch eine lösung die man
mit in die überlegungen einbezieht das
macht man ja auch jetzt schon es gibt
der arbeitsgruppen die mit den
verschiedenen stellen von bund ländern
oder koch institut und auch den
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen die sich
gerade um diese dinge zur zeit gedanken
machen dass polen ist vor allen dingen
dann eine gute idee wenn man nicht
erwartet oder keine gute idee sein wenn
man nicht erwartet dass man sehr viele
positive fälle hat wenn man zum beispiel
beim ausbruchsgeschehen dann eben diese
untersuchung macht dann hat man schon
sehr schnell in den pools teilen es
jetzt 8 oder 10 proben dann doch einen
positiven dabei und dann wird es eben
mehr arbeit weil man dann praktisch den
pool auflösen muss und einzeln nach
testen muss und das ist dann am ende
mehr arbeit als wenn man eben gar nicht
geholt hätte polen kann eben wie gesagt
man reine routine macht es gibt keinen
hinweis dass irgendwer infiziert ist und
dann macht es eben zum aufnahme
screening oder ähnlichem
da kann man das sicherlich überlegen
aber auch dann muss man es ein
vermehrter logistische aufwand weil eben
die die proben zuordenbar gemacht werden
müssen und aufbewahrt werden müssen bis
das ergebnis da ist und und weiteres
aber eine grundsätzliche möglichkeit ist
das und das ist auch gegenstand der
gegenwärtigen überlegungen
wir gehen zuvor eckert sie waren
deutsches ärzteblatt wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere
[Musik]
ein geschäft der zoom-funktion
eventuelle fiel gegen mittag um auf
probleme führten karten ja dass das ist
so also in der regel ist es so dass bei
personen die schon eine eingeschränkte
lungenfunktion haben der mund
nasenschutz auch gar nicht toleriert
wird die die wollen den nicht die merken
dass sehr schnell selber diese diese
patienten und personen dass ihnen das
nicht gut tut weil es ist selbst ein
einfacher mund nasenschutz ein gewisser
zusätzliche arten widerstand und dann
sollte man eben auch diese personen
nicht zu stark motivieren hier jetzt
diese diesen mund nasenschutz zu tragen
dann ist es eben umso wichtiger dass
sich die personen die hier in der pflege
oder im haushalt mit diesen personen die
diese erkrankung haben umgehen dass die
eben den passiven den fremdschutz dann
auch tatsächlich durchführen und selbst
einen mund nasen schutz aufsetzen
vielen dank
wir gehen zum bayern reporter marcus
reuter die markierungen haben wir sind
wir machen
halten sie davon wie es andere länder
machen das teilweise werden dass sie dem
haus gebracht wird müssen also die
maßnahmen so lange das unter 1 ist es
grundsätzlich erstmal ausreichend das
hauptproblem besteht glaube ich darin zu
gewährleisten dass es eben unter 1
bleibt also jetzt auf die breite
betrachtung gesehen auf die betrachtung
was geschieht deutschlandweit dann muss
man natürlich auch sehen es gibt eben
immer auch auf großereignisse und diese
ausbrüche ereignisse sorgen dann auch
dafür die schlagen sich natürlich nieder
in unseren melde statistiken und die
sorgen dann auch dafür dass das er mal
kurzfristig wieder nach oben macht wenn
diese ausbrüche größer sind es gibt ja
durchaus auch ausbrüche mit mehreren
also mit personen im zweistelligen oder
gar dreistelligen bereich und die die
sieht man dann eben auch im eher und an
diesen hot spots oder wie man es nennen
will in diesem cluster gebieten
da kann es dann eben aber schon auch
sein dass zusätzliche maßnahmen
erforderlich sind zusätzliche maßnahmen
des infektionsschutz die daneben und
genau dort ganz spezifisch dann auch
angewandt werden
man hat natürlich das repertoire dass
man immer hat isolierung quarantäne und
so weiter und das muss dann aber eben
zusätzlich dort vor ort noch angewandt
werden so dass ich denke man kann sagen
in der in der fläche haben wir ja ein
ganz gutes niveau an schutzmaßnahmen zur
zeit müssen aufpassen dass wir das nicht
zu zügig reduzieren und wo dann eben die
die örtliche notwendigkeit besteht
entsprechend schärfere maßnahmen zu
machen dann dann sollte man das dort
eben auch durchführen
vielen dank wir gehen zu frau christel
von bloomberg news
[Musik]
in welchen worten oder in welchen teilen
der gesellschaft in die listen und
lieblingsmusik andy zusammenhang mit
artikeln und kann singen und ist davon
auszugehen himmel hinblick auf eine
mögliche quelle des im herbst ihre
größte veranstaltung also ich würde
immer denken also einfach aus der aus
der erfahrung an ganz am beginn dieser
jetzt laufenden epidemischen welle das
dass die jungen menschen schon also die
jugendlichen und jungen erwachsenen
schon eine gewisse schlüsselrolle
spielen was so die ausbreitung in der
gesellschaft angeht weil wir einfach
selbst kaum symptome haben bzw
nur sehr wenig symptome also mobil
sowieso sind dann auch mobil bleiben
auch natürlich viele gesellschaftliche
ereignisse mitmachen wollen sich mit
freunden treffen und ähnlichen und dann
aber auch schon in dieser
asymptomatischen phase des virus
ausscheiden können also das scheint mir
ein punkt zu sein
sehr wichtig ist und der andere punkt
ist eben
es sind eben die gruppen die
letztendlich in heim und
gemeinschaftsunterkünften sind die sind
eben besonders gefährdet und da kann das
virus wenn es denn dort erst einmal fuß
gefasst hat in so einer einrichtung sich
auch sehr schnell verbreiten
das haben wir ja auch mehrfach gesehen
in der letzten zeit und das hat auch
dafür gefühlt dazu geführt dass in der
zweiten phase sagen wir mal ab mitte
märz sind etwa gerade in der
altersgruppe der älteren sehr stark oder
stark steigende fallzahlen waren und die
im moment auch noch stark betroffen sind
also ich würde denken die älteren
personen sind auf der einen seite
sicherlich gefährdet und das ist auch
ein höheres risiko dass es da auf grund
der lebensweise eben zu zu ausbrüchen
kommen kann und
die jungen erwachsenen wäre meine
einschätzung aber ich muss auch zugeben
harten daten außer der beobachtungen aus
der aus den letzten wochen können wir
das zurzeit sieht sich zukünftig
entwickeln wird eigentlich noch nicht
belegen
vielen dank wir gehen zur radio in
münchen die frau schmidt und bevor ich
die forsch mit häufig deformiert das
wort geben noch die bitte dass
diejenigen die ihre frage schon gestellt
haben auf das symbol noch mal geben
damit sie aus der liste herausfallen
es wird nicht möglich sein noch eine
zweite frage zu stellen die liste ist
noch relativ lang vor schmid als
bundesbehörde für infektionskrankheiten
sind sie prädestiniert und verlasen
masken zu sagen wohin hat schon
angesprochen ist jetzt nicht über das
licht geworden was tragen betrifft ja
nicht nur die verbraucher die jetzt
woods oder eine halbe stunde oder stunde
im laden gehen sondern auch die
verkäufer oder zugbegleiter die dann
über den ganzen tag sie masken tragen
müssen
es ist ganz egal welche selbst gebastelt
passt wenn eure kauften massen ist
datensicherheit die sauerstoffsättigung
betreffend ab auch ob jetzt das
bakterielle milieu dass dadurch vor mund
und nase geschaffen wird und darüber
einen langen zeitraum immer wieder
diskutiert wird schädigen kann und dass
ein eventuell austretende scofield 19
virus durch dieses feuchte klima unter
der maske nicht eventuell sogar mitglied
wird
da können sie diese beiden szenarien
hier ja also zunächst mal die sache mit
dem sound mit der sauerstoffsättigung
vielleicht fange ich da mal an also die
arten barriere bei normalen mund nasen
schutz ist nicht sehr stark gleich wo
ich hatte schon gesagt bei bestimmten
personen die mit ihrer lungenfunktion an
der grenze sind kann das als unangenehm
empfunden werden und kann das auch
sozusagen ein entscheidender faktor sein
denn so blitzt das merken die aber die
die wollen dann diese masken nicht auf
haben
einen normalen gesunden jungen gesunden
entschuldigungen da sehe ich da
eigentlich kein problem
zur ja sag ich mal bakteriellen
besiedelung mann soll diese mund nasen
schutz tragen oder nur so lange tragen
dass sie durch gefürchtet sind dann
müssen die entweder wenn es
wegwerfprodukte sind halt weggeworfen
werden oder eben wenn es ein stoff
produkt ist gewaschen werden oder sonst
wie gepflegt werden
wenn das wenn ja noch sagen immer sonst
sauber ist und nur durch gefürchtet
reich vielleicht auch die stoffmaske zu
trocknen und anschließend heißt zu
bügeln dann hat man da auch in dessen
desinfektions infekt kultivierung des
virus das so nicht möglich also dass
virus vermehrt sich nur das ist eine
eigenschaft von viren auf auf
körperzellen es braucht also ein wird
das kann höchstens angereichert werden
dann von innen wenn man selbst mit 19
infiziert ist dann ist natürlich je mehr
tröpfchen sich da sammeln dann reichert
sich das an
und dann kann man wenn das ein
infizierter getragen hat der virus
ausscheidet davon ausgehen dass auch
eine gewisse zeit von innen
vermehrungsfähige svi russland an dem
mund nasen schutz ist deswegen muss man
den auch dann wenn man ihn abgesetzt hat
eben schnell entsorgen und sollen ihnen
nicht irgendwo rumliegen lassen also
hygiene auch beim absetzen
wie gesagt dass das virus sich dort
aktiv vermehrt ist nicht möglich
vielen dank wir gehen zu albrecht
klöpfer sagen sie nochmal ihre
redaktionen dazu bitte ich habe das
trage zur kleinräumigkeit
[Musik]
der kann ja das ist ja ein
durchschnittswert und das karnickel
morgen geboren in zerkall im jahr wert
geben werde meinen ihrer hohen gibt das
heißt wir müssen bereit ich bin zweiter
statistik daneben laufen lassen wie dies
das kleinräumige geschehen zeigt und wie
ist die aktuelle lage und reicht das was
das bundesministerium für gesundheit
jetzt beschlossen hat mit der
aufstellung der gesundheitsämter als ist
das was nicht ausreichend um das
kleinräumige geschieden ausreichen also
das ist völlig richtig wir beobachten
hier einen zusammengesetzten wert aus
mehreren lokalen geschehen und in den
bundesländern hatte ich schon gesagt ist
ist das auch unterschiedlich dieser er
null wert irgendwann macht es aber
keinen sinn mehr mit der null zu
arbeiten also unterhalb der
bundeslandebene wird es schwierig weil
man doch eine gewisse fallzahl braucht
um ihr auf einigermaßen stabile aussagen
zu kommen also wenn das zu wenig fälle
werden mit anderen worten dann kann man
keinen stabilen er null wert mehr
berechnen weil jeder einzelne fall oder
auch zwei fälle wenn die an einem tag
auftauchen dann bereits einen so starken
aufschlag machen würden das ist dass es
keine sinnvollen ergebnissen gibt also
darunter kann man das im grunde nicht
berechnet was man dann natürlich hat das
sind die die die fall meldung
und da sieht man ja wenn man vor ort ist
in einem gesundheitsamt und man hat hier
eben mehrere fälle die in einem gewissen
zeitraum zb aus einer schule oder aus
einem altenheim oder aus einer anderen
einrichtung gemeldet werden da sieht man
das ja unmittelbar und kann unmittelbar
auf dieses geschehen reagieren da sieht
man dann auch sehr schnell ja die
dynamik wenn am nächsten tag eben
weitere fälle dazukommen meinetwegen
nochmal das doppelte oder ähnliches dann
kann man darauf reagieren und das ist ja
auch das gute an unserer meldesystem es
wird ja immer sage ich mal bemängelt
dass es so lange dauert das die zahlen
vom gesundheitsamt dann über die
landesstellen am rk ii sind es dauert
einige tage im schnitt sechs tage bis
eine woche sage ich mal
vielleicht auch mal acht tage aber das
gute ist eben das eben das
gesundheitsamt zuerst dieses geschehen
auch hat also keine wenn man jetzt eine
direkte meldung ausschließliche direkte
meldung von den laboren ans lka hätten
dann wäre das sicherlich schneller aber
diese information was passiert bei mir
vor ort die ist natürlich wichtig für
das gesundheitsamt zu reagieren und da
zählt im grunde jeder einzelne fall für
das ist viel wichtiger für die bereits
der wert insofern denke ich dass man da
schon ein die möglichkeit hat dieses ist
dieses geschehen sensitiv und zu
entdecken
und wenn die maßnahmen umgesetzt sind
die jetzt vorgeschlagen sind also was
die personelle stärkung der
gesundheitsämter angeht dann ist das
eine sehr viel stärkere position als die
gesundheitsämter vorher hatten es ist
viel handarbeit die dazu tun ist weil
dieser kontakt ermittlung und bei der
isolierung von patienten das wird dann
eine deutliche verbesserung sein und
wird sicherlich dazu führen dass das
ausbrüche deutlich besser bearbeitet
werden können das da bin ich sehr
optimistisch ob das dann nicht wenn man
also auf der anderen seite muss man
natürlich sagen wenn wir jetzt alle
maßnahmen wegnehmen würden und uns nur
noch darauf verlassen würden
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt bei einer
relativ hohen ausgangszahl von täglichen
neuinfektionen von 2001 kann dass es
geschehen allerdings so dynamisch werden
dass das man da einfach nicht hinterher
kommt damit keiner manpower wird man das
dann schaffen wenn es endlich ins
exponentielle wachstum geht deswegen
braucht man beides und deswegen ist es
auch zurzeit sicherlich nicht die lösung
zu sagen wir stärken die
gesundheitsämter und nehmen dann alle
maßnahmen weg und dann wird das schon
irgendwie laufen sondern man muss diese
maßnahmen die ergriffen worden sind und
die wirksam sind eben sehr sorgfältig
erwägen welche man schritt für schritt
ihren rausnehmen kann aus dem geschehen
um das dann zu beobachten
um dieses fragile gleichgewicht was ich
da so als art waage eingestellt hat im
moment schlägt die waage mehr in unsere
richtung also
haben das pre aber auch nicht viel das
ganze ist noch wackelig dass diese wagen
nicht umschlägt vielen dank wir haben
jetzt noch drei anfragen die werden wir
hoffentlich alle noch schaffen wenn die
anfragen und auch die antworten kurz
sind
herr hering von medico direkt jan sie
vielen dank ich komme mal zum testen
[Musik]
das patient ins bett gekommen und nicht
gab und bieten das innovativste an die
investoren allerdings mussten
als dass diese bitte kurze frage hätte
eine kurze frage ja also es gibt im
moment eine große zahl von testen die
auf dem markt angeboten sind die auch
erst mal eine zertifikat haben also ich
sag mal schnell evaluiert sind also so
dass es eben ein zertifikat geben kann
und die dann aber nochmal darüber hinaus
wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen
unterzogen werden das kann ich im moment
nicht sagen wann wann diese
untersuchungen fertig sein werden also
im moment ist es teile ich die
einschätzung von herrn drosten für
epidemiologische studien ist es
sicherlich geeignet wenn man vor serum
hat von dem patienten und man sieht dass
seine zero konversion stattgefunden hat
also tatsächlich sich neue antikörper
gebildet haben dann wird der ein oder
andere testen jetzt auf dem markt sind
sicherlich auch schon geeignet seien
aber dass man ähnlich wie bei einer
hepatitis theologie sichere aussagen
machen kann
das ist zur zeit noch nicht der fall ich
rechne damit in den nächsten monaten
aber ein genaues datum kann ich ihnen
damit nicht sagen kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen
er fällt nicht ja wir haben
ja also diesen faktor 3 das ist ja jetzt
kein geheimnis dass ist ich habe mich da
jetzt bezogen auf die einzige
serologische studie die es zurzeit in
deutschland gibt das ist die wie der
kollege strecken in heinsberg gemacht
hat da gibt es ja noch keine details
wieder publiziert sind ich kenne da auch
nur die daten die im grunde jeder kennt
und da war eben die angabe etwa faktor 3
das scheint mir auch ganz grund ganz gut
plausibel jetzt erstmal zu sein und
deckt sich auch mit der mit der mit mit
verschiedenen modellen dies aus
verschiedenen weltregionen gibt es gibt
auch modellierungen dazu in deutschland
die sagen die unter erfassung ist in der
letzten in den letzten wochen gesunken
auch in etwa auf diesen faktor 3 aus
modellen heraus also das ist kein
abschließender wert das hatte ich ja
auch eingangs gesagt sondern dieser wert
wird sich noch sicherlich stabilisieren
oder auch vielleicht in die eine oder
andere richtung abweichen das ist das
was zur zeit bekannt ist und
grundsätzlich denke ich ist das auch
plausibel
vielen dank
als letztes jetzt jacob moore frau herr
jacobo planet interview
durch kinder also es gibt ja schon in
den letzten tagen verschiedene berichte
zur deckung gefallen von kindern und
kleinkinder ausgeht können sie nochmal
kurz erklären und welche
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse haben
sie unsere schule und peter schließen
raten und 2
also es ist in der tat so die datenlage
ist da nicht nicht eindeutig ist jetzt
auch gerade ganz frisch studie nochmal
von den niederländischen kollegen in
erschienen die auch gesagt haben oder
die jetzt gesagt haben dass kinder für
die übertragung keine große rolle zu
spielen scheinen das ist nicht so dass
sie keine rolle spielen
es gibt auch andere hinweise die in eine
andere richtung gehen und anlass für uns
war eben jetzt endlich einmal das ist
sicherlich sicherlich also das alles
analogie schlüsse ja das muss man sagen
weil es gibt eben widersprüchliche daten
dazu und in analogie schluss muss man
aber sagen und das schien uns erst mal
wenn man auf der seite auf der seite der
vorsicht bleiben will und ich glaube das
ist auch hier geboten schien uns das
auch gerechtfertigt so zu argumentieren
wir sehen eben einerseits dass kinder
obwohl sie eben selten symptome haben
und auch selten zum arzt geht und
deshalb in der melde- statistik selten
vorkommen dass sie durchaus wenn man mal
rückwärts ermittelt und kinder als
kontaktpersonen hat dass es eben
durchaus auch infektionen bei kindern
dann gibt und zwar in einem in einem
umfang der dem vom erwachsenen nicht so
stark unter sie sich nicht so stark
unterscheidet das sind dann eben auch so
um die sieben prozent
es ist punkt eins also es gibt
infektionen bei kindern und 52 war dass
es eben auch hinweise gibt dass auch
asymptomatisch personen also personen
die nicht husten oder niesen im
erwachsenenbereich durchaus das virus
übertragen können das also
asymptomatische virus ausscheider für
die infektion eine rolle spielen
und genau das sind dann diese kinder die
haben keine symptome aber die haben das
virus das repliziert in deren rachen das
kann man auch messen und insofern kommen
sie grundsätzlich als virus ausscheider
da auch in frage und dann ist eben der
dritte punkt dass sie eben auch sage ich
mal eben nicht unbedingt zumindest wenn
es die jüngeren kinder sind die husten
und niesen regeln entsprechend einheiten
können oder immer einheiten und das
natürlich auch dann zu einer doch wenn
die mal symptome haben dann auch zu
einer stärkeren übertragung führen kann
das sind anschlüsse dann zusätzlich weiß
man eben auch dass das bei der influenza
das der fall ist in finanzkreisen
anderes krankheitsbild keine frage aber
durch dass das kinder heben durch ihr
durch ihr verhalten hier durchaus auch
eine rolle spielen können deswegen
hatten wir hier zur vorsicht geraten
und wir werden uns jetzt hier die
weiteren daten anderer kollegen angucken
wie weit man sagen kann
kinder spielen infektionsgeschehen eine
rolle oder eben nicht und wir sind
natürlich auch aber überlegen wie man
jetzt wo die schulschließung wieder
aufgehoben werden oder die schulen
wieder eröffnet werden
mit welchen epidemiologischen methoden
sich man hier dann nähern kann um zu um
eine abschätzung zu machen wie groß die
perfekte waren bei der einführung das
ist alles sehr schnell gegangen hatten
wir nicht die gelegenheit und man muss
eben auch sagen dass diese maßnahmen ja
nicht als einzelmaßnahme eingeführte
wurden sondern mit mehreren anderen
zusammen und das ist dann hier praktisch
nicht möglich ist ein einzel effekte auf
gesellschaftsebene zu messen
jetzt müssen wir sehen ob das jetzt
möglich ist und da machen wir uns
derzeit gedanken
vielen dank dann sind wir jetzt zum ende
gekommen und sehen uns oder wir hören
uns planmäßig nächsten dienstag 28 april
wieder und für die ganz langfristigen
planungen der erste mai ist der feiertag
also der reguläre freitag wird dann auf
den donnerstag vorverlegt vielen dank
ich dagegen bewegen